oh the beard oh so manly I just want to
touch it
ah hi everybody
ah nothing to see here just I was
checking out the Hall of Fame interior
you did I didn't invite you to here so
soon Johnny wait um okay huh so we're
playing oh yeah welcome back to let's
play it's hurting my eyes so um we're
going back to our house now okay anyways
we're doing fine now we're going on the
long drive back yeah wait a minute wait
a minute that wasn't there before you
can't fool me
something's change something changed
okay come on
oh hi it's a whole family of you
[ __ ] out hey how's it going friend
how you doing how you doing there you
doing good you doing good ride alright
alright bye bye
what the hell are you doing okay that's
weird you just you just carry on there
you you do whatever feels right that
wasn't there before that is from
freaking Starcraft why is that in there
I think I don't know I give up I give up
my give up
Agatha don't care not going to question
anything that happens from now on
well thank you very much and why did
that pull me in oh no it just launched
me up never mind thank you very much mr.
tank seems tank how are you doing oh
look I'm stopping by the shop oh wait no
my car my truck broke down
makes perfect sense my fuel is out yes
my food is out otherwise foiiowed I've
been in this shop another note the milk
plain to her the fine news failing
that's foods waffle funky kupuna they
didn't chuck him out on Soundcloud and
used orb
okey dokey look at the guys dancing
outside I are the goin friend not weird
at all okay anyway carrying on perfectly
normal hello
how's everybody know the time only comes
out when somebody sneezes that problem
no okay
well is that I don't recognize that
don't know this hello for you you can't
find nothing without credit mm-hmm
Richard don't know this I don't know
many enemies
okay okay knives ears some up here
nothing arrivin a ride little piggies
mini piggies anything else nope all
right a dog's head why do I need a dog's
head no does anybody need this here
excuse me sorry what are you
see someone scan that man someone scan
this see what it does a download link in
the game okay shut up mr. Dean all
Rocko's Modern Life
I know I know are you losing hello you
enjoy playing this game good for you I
whatever whatever shut up shut up shut
up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut
up I don't want to hear any of your sass
I don't want to hear any of your sass
okay you got peppers pepper excuse me
sir excuse me look at all the new
release of loot all the new releases up
your nose okay pop your nose with a
rubber hose how about you mr. Ahn hey hi
hey hol look at this hey sir sir Sir sir
wait hang on sir sir sir does this smell
like pepper fudge if I could use it on
myself no object a you lose it on ya hey
nothin what I hell what the hell are you
do
he's been busier than mono mada
okie-dokie you see alongside for the
yeah a new spell and believe me go fry
fry so duck where it is life balloon
okay
it's ballooning thank you one omnipotent
taller Taylor hello I've got a freaking
tailor here and shout down here what
you're either buddy
you're right you okay alright I'll I'll
go now you just received fuel for your
car go home now you're drunk I suppose
whatever you say man okay I'm out of
here
goodbye okay alright that made sense
judgment in anything else I think I feel
Dumber for this entire experience I
think I feel much much much more
stupider alright am i back home now can
I rest really really sons of [ __ ]
y'all came leaking out hi there you
don't ok hello hello goodbye who you are
I'm guessing I'm on Anita take one of
these with me thought I saw something in
there here you're coming with me
don't know what the hell you are don't
know what that grunting is we're
expecting
okay all right hey freeze out how you
doing I'm here for the cake come right
up right all right all right all right
hello hello hello you can touch me all
the time
ooh my save me time oh hi vegeta how you
doing
could you could you really that'd make
my dreams come true
look god damn it all right we're just
gonna have a party for it
everybody dance oh I'm a little dizzy
okay who the hell are you change the
music
smooth mcgroove just did a song on this
or not just it but he did a song on this
and it was amazing his acapella version
wait I know this one oh it's on the tip
of my tongue
yeah I've no idea but I bump it up
enough I love them okay anyway Goku
Kakarot carrot cup in your house dancing
like a prowler for you what the hell are
you thank you for playing my story
you're welcome if you sneeze I please as
waves goes wait hang on I guess that's
it that's the end of the game that was
something else
hello I gotta imagine that there had to
be easier game engines to play this on
but whatever I'm out
I've had enough insanity to last a
lifetime and so glorious guy came to
attend you are full of cake and the
music is still playing in your head but
tomorrow is just another boring day I
hope you enjoyed playing this thing
thanks to toast waffle and Sigma SS lava
electrode special thanks to all my
friends and last but not least thanks to
you for playing use contents and the
rights belong to their respective owners
well thank you all for watching this bit
of insanity here I'm not saying it was
bad in any way it was actually quite
quite interesting
yeah I'll go with interesting all right
I'll sit with injured so anyway thank
you guys who recommended it that was
pretty insane don't know what to say
other Matt so okay well thank you all so
much for watching I guess click the
annotation for more videos since I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
I
ah